yoku todo is a internet television
platform you can call us a multi-screen
entertainment platform where over 400
million users watches videos on PC
mobile phone tablets as well as
interactive television so basically
people come find and view videos across
these different screens in China people
call us the YouTube of China because we
are the largest video platform in China
from that standpoint we're very similar
to YouTube but unlike YouTube we don't
just focus on user-generated content I
think a combination of original content
and syndicated content gives a much
wider breadth of video content so users
come to our platform where there is
material they see on television stations
or in the movie screens or on the
Internet screens it's actually widely
available so it's not just focus on
user-generated content because if you
look at when YouTube first started for
example there were a lot of
user-generated content because I recall
when I was here at Stanford America's
Funniest Home Videos was around so the
DV coach has been around for a very long
time in China when we started a company
back in no five or six TV has not been
around very long time penetration of a
very low so if we want to do a pure
YouTube user generated model there
wouldn't be a lot of content and you
wouldn't be able to scale the platform
but on the other hand we went and work
with a lot of television stations as
well as the production companies in
China and increasingly around the world
to bring this content to the Chinese
audience and that enriches the platform
and six years ago both Youku and Tudou
also started developing its own original
content which has actually done very
well and you see some online video
websites here in the US also have had
successes doing original content but I
think for in China the breadth of the
content that we produce actually is
broader in the sense that besides TV
series will do micro movies we do
shows we do documentaries we do
animation also we do entertainment news
so a breadth of different content that's
actually produced on new quinta dough
for us is mostly working with
independent studios as well as
independent directors and not
necessarily the very very large based TV
stations or establish production
companies those ones we actually also do
we call them joint productions and so
for the original content it's really
what we call what native is really born
from the web and design for the web
audience what's really significantly
different here is you look at the
audience of like an HBO or Netflix
they're actually quite similar because
internet penetration in us is so high
but in China internet only serves only
part of the audience whereas the
television audience maybe from five
years old all the way to 75 the instant
audience in the PC world went from about
18 to 35 and now with the mobile phone a
bit broader to 15 to 45 but still urban
young educated and very much an market
opportunity where you can provide
content for that specific audience in
contrast to the overall television
content that needs to address to a much
broader demographic
recently we've got a show caught on the
road which is a very interesting couple
who met each other over 20 years ago in
high school and started a company
together selling tofu machines and they
sold the company after they were
actually went to volunteer at a citron
earthquake and realized that life is
short they sold the company and they
started traveling all around the world
in some of the most adventurous places
places like weather Chernobyl nuclear
plant Somalia where Black Hawk Down was
filmed and so forth and the fella in the
show his nickname to cemani because it's
a pre heavyset guy basically a promise
his girlfriend at the time very very
unique wedding so towards the end of the
first season actually proposed her in
the North Pole and in the second season
the collarbone and traveled from China
Asia to North America South America and
then actually all the way down to
Antarctica where they got married in the
South Pole and we had a live broadcast
from Beijing at a time where we invited
their mothers so they could actually
witness the wedding real time and they
are now on their way to South Africa and
then to Brazil for the World Cup so this
is actually a phenomenal phenomenal
series but as I point out this is just
one example of a broad breadth of
different kinds of content that we
create we felt that we really needed to
come up with the kind of the benchmarks
or the case examples in a much broader
John rabe because we have not seen those
kind of what native programming and
China indeed other parts of the world
especially the last two years it's
really called multi-screen whether it's
mobile phone or tablet and increasingly
into the smart TVs with mobile phone
probably changing everything because of
its overall reach which is actually much
broader even than PC and our mobile
traffic now actually exceeds our PC
traffic all only after a very short
period of time so the idea of
consumption of multi-screen as viewers
are watching us on these different
screens become very very interesting
especially in Asia where our users
actually take public transportation so
they may be watching a show halfway
through a show in the subway and then
one that time they get home do you want
to watch the rest of the show on a
different screen whether it's tablet or
their interactive television so our
product needs to really cater to that
change in setting environment and and
we've been able to track that through
cloud-based services and our product
features that well now both the viewing
habits as well as the recommendations
based on big data driven by the
different screens different times of
days and the different user experience
as we move to multi-screen expecially
with the mobile phone the whole idea of
call to action as well as commerce
become possible because when it was just
on the PC screen you are there in the
home on the office so the mobile screen
is with you all the time and it's close
to where you buy where you decide to eat
and so forth
and so all these consumption is
happening as you're watching this video
and the other trend we're seeing is
probably more interactivity where as
people are viewing the video it's not
like a linear experience or one-way
experience where people are starting to
interact and we're building product
features that help them interact and as
they think about taking certain course
of action after you give you a piece of
content for example there may be product
placements within a video that they
decide to want to buy right away or they
can click to buy certain items where
there's a discount 30 yards down the
road so these kinds of things will
become more more interesting as mobile
penetration and video consumption grows
and as we come up with different product
features that will actually bring these
technology to bear well I think if you
were to start a business right now I
always say because we're not like 20
years ago when when we started the
internet business where there were no
incumbents now there are a lot of big
players in the market who have
established market position so you need
to certainly innovate faster and
certainly identify market opportunities
really that's different and unique from
the incumbents shall we say to always
pick areas that are not necessarily easy
if it's an easy area then it's very easy
for other people replicate so you know
whole idea of entry barriers the whole
idea of think about whether it's a
product or a technology barrier that can
really help you as an early stage
company differentiate as well as lead
the whole cooperation sharing culture
here which really differentiates
Stanford culture I think what's really
well I think when a startup environment
where you really need to work together
as team teamwork is very important
whereas we work with a very large
enterprise or example your individual
and then you're competing in the
corporate leather which is very
different from a wholly stage the other
thing I think is the opportunity having
been here and be exposed of all the
entrepreneurs and and the venture
capitalist that come to class you
somehow I was a mesmerized or or
inspired by all these great stories
whether they are success stories or
failure stories about the journeys
they've taken as well as what that means
as a professional career and so I think
that's just something that's very
valuable for the Stanford experience I
think just being in the valley has deep
roots in terms of entrepreneurism as
well as venture capital so you'll find
that a lot of the GSB alums in in China
and Asia also reflect that so you see a
much higher concentration in terms of
whether it's within the founder team
early stage company or whether it is
within the private equity and venture
capital world
as we are building up our consumer
business the expertise in those areas
will help us grow our consumer business
whether it's a subscription or
membership also as well and other
interactive services that we're trying
to build and so working together as
we're thinking about the intersection
between video and commerce as well as
from a big data standpoint how the
commerce and payment data will help our
advertising partners what we will be
quite interesting also having more
financial resources will also help us
grow more aggressively in the new
businesses whether it's the consumer
business whether it's our original
content whether as we think about the
multi-screen moving to the Smart TV
platform as well so moving from the
distribution production as well as the
business model standpoint these
strategic and financial resources will
help your quota Doak grow much faster as
well as much much more leave a bench in
terms of resources